lina tu sais que jacques brel est mort
il ya dix ans et quand on se rencontre
on peut pas s'empêcher de penser à lui
est ce que tu pourrais nous nous
expliquer pourquoi tu as choisi cette
chanson ne me quitte pas enfin comment
tu l'a découverte à ce qui s'est passé
j'étais à new york avec des amis qui
vient souvent m'a permis on était dans
son bureau et il m'a dit je veux te
faire apprendre une chanson tu es
capable de bien à chanter ne me quitte
pas à l'époque je ne savais pas ce que
cela voulait dire aimer le disque et moi
je ne comprenais pas du tout ce que
c'est vrai disait mais quand j'ai
entendu ne me quitte pas je me suis mise
à pleurer
j'ai dit à mon ami je sais que c'est une
chanson très triste que ce type est
désespérée mais je ne sais pas pourquoi
et la mêlée française l adorer la france
et m'expliquer ce que le titre va dit il
me dit tu devrais l'apprendre parce que
tu la chantera bien elle parce que doit
elle aimerait bien que tu le fasses
heures alors j'ai commencé à travailler
cette chance en jouant fine se fait aux
états unis je ne me devais absolument
pas que ça allait me rendre parler en
france un moment la chanson dit je
creuserait je ne pouvais pas cependant
cette roseraie et je n'arrivais pas non
plus à des rois et loi et pendant deux
ans
quand je travaillais cette chanson aux
suisses j'ai été obligé de faire des
exceptions pour ces deux mots croît et
loire et pour la phrase qui fait ou la
mousse et la loi et la mousse et le roi
et je sers et rennes ça m'a pris deux
ans d'apprendre la défense par le hair
est là elle accueille encore les
premiers c'est pas du jeu correctement à
la mais à cela mais bien parce que je
chantais cette chanson j'ai rencontré
jacques une fois dans un ascenseur à
genève
il m'a dit et je suis très content que
tu chantes machin je voudrais dire
quelque chose d'autre à propos de brel
au maroc au sénégal dans tous les pays
francophones
on aime beaucoup cette chanson et qu'on
pourra les morts je n'oublierai jamais
ce moment je venais acheter un chapeau
en afrique un chapeau en paille et quand
il est mort ce matin là j'ai eu un choc
j'étais à genève on m'a dit il est mort
et j'ai répondu on va tuer et je me suis
dit ça il fait mieux car je ne vais pas
tenir longtemps si jacques boileux non
je ne tenais pas à ma taille dans la mer
comme ça ah non j'ai pris mon cher
et je les brûle et je n'ai en fait un
sacrifice pour ça nous va depuis quand
je parle un peu trop de ça je ne savais
pas que tu allais pas boudé cette
question je me mets à pleurer
j'ai apprécié un nombre accru
il avait un talent extraordinaire et
c'était un grand bonhomme
oui j'aurais aimé le connaître
personnellement c'est tout ce que je
peux dire sur cette chanson nina li na
la france des mets toi est ce que tu
aimes la france
j'aime beaucoup la fois un jour à paris
tu as dis tout ça c'est nul c'est des
conneries à part la haute couture a pas
quoi
la haute couture haute couture je n'ai
jamais dit ça ce que je dis c'est que la
france avait changé que la france ait
trop de ressembler aux américains avec
le brigitte vous qu'ils essaient de se
comporter comme ça m'ennuie je ne
voulais pas que la france change
je trouvais que la france devait
protéger sa culture sa langue son
originalité et arrêter de copier
frénétiquement des américains c'est tout
ce que je dis et c'est ça que je veux
dit ok on a compris que lui tout
maintenant j'ai gardé l'appartement à
hollywood au 7205 enfants pleine avenue
et me sert de bureau
en ce moment je suis en train d'acheter
un appartement entre hollande hollande
mécontent ce que les gens m'aiment bien
là bas le mans n'a pas joué en enfance
alors des problèmes d'argent
je crois que le monde entier a des
problèmes d'argent mais tu as dit que tu
avais jamais vu la couleur de tes droits
d'auteur je ne peux pas là tout ça c'est
de passer
je suis très contente que l'histoire de
madagascar me soit arrivée ici je suis
ravi d'être enfant c'est maintenant
passons à une autre question
je veux pas en parler non je ne veux pas
sauter de bien en fait c'est n'y avait
pas eu un moment délicat ce qui est fait
mais je ne serai pas et c'est avec toi
mais je voulais pas en dire du mal c'est
juste parce que cette chanson était
prise dans ton premier album et que tu
n'étais même pas au courant c'est tout
j'en savais bien tu sais encore herbe
quand as tu décidé de quitter les états
unis pour l'afrique c'est en quelle
année
[Musique]
mon dieu ça fait 20 ans voyons voir j'ai
quitté l'amérique en 1973
je me suis installé au liberia en
afrique orientale
je ne vais pas renoncer j'ai passé 5 et
d'y haute je suis rentré aux états unis
je voulais demander à ma mère son avis
sur le vieux type que je venais de me
trouver c'est à dire madame et avec les
cas je devais me marier est simple et cd
mais si ces cdd senior elle avait 70 ans
elle était très riche elle avait un
élevage de porcs à vie au lit je ne
pouvais pas faire grand chose et il m'a
dit de venir lui marié six semaines plus
tard je suis à la fois ma mère pleurait
devant des scènes
et là j'ai vraiment fait une bêtise
parce qu'ils ne savaient pas que mon
rejoindre quand je suis rentré au
liberia j'ai appris que son fils qui est
ministre de la culture avait été tué je
ne m'en suis jamais remise de cette
histoire voilà c'est la première fois
que je quittais le maire comme installer
quelques pas et je ne vais pas arrêter
par dupuis même si j'ai perdu ma maman
j'ai vécu à la barbade en suisse a perdu
trois ans tu as tu es au courant et
maintenant chapiteau d'une cette manière
je cherche toujours dennis était très
préoccupé par le problème noirs aux
états unis tu crois qu'il est résolu
maintenant
[Musique]
maintenant c'est un problème économique
elle est moins marquée qu'au vin aux
états unis en ce moment le problème
c'est l'argent
tout le monde se bat pour gagner de
l'argent et les inégalités entre les
riches et les pauvres n'ont jamais été
aussi forte et c'est les noirs
américains ne s'accroche pas comme des
malades pour gagner plus d'argent
c'était quatre secondes et encore le
fossé s'agrandit tu dis c'est çà et là
bas les gens ne pensent qu'aux gagner de
l'argent je ne peux donc pas dire quand
la situation se soit réellement
améliorer le problème martial s'est
atténuée oui les gens sont beaucoup
moins obsédés par les différences
raciales depuis jamais le problème
économique a pris beaucoup d'importance
ce qui veut dire que les inégalités sont
les mêmes même si elle semble différente
sans argent tu n'es rien que tout soit
blanc ou noir
mais le plus souvent les plus pauvres
sans les noix ouais tu veux dire que
c'est plus une question d'argent qui
l'ont question de couleur exactement
c'est une question d'argent
tu penses quoi du succès de musique sud
africaine
je suis tout ce que je dirai ça je m'en
fous et boit le champagne
je ne veux pas être associé avec
l'afrique du sud où que ce soit et en
france en hollande en suisse et sept je
m'en fous je ne veux pas qu'on puisse
dire que j'ai fait une déclaration du
négatif ou positif au sujet du super nes
en ceux qui comme un moine classement
j'espère que ce pays devrait être rayé
de la carte
et ça vaut pour les noix et pour les
blancs et donnez moi une cigarette
pourquoi parce que c'est un pays de fous
je veux même pas en parler même pour
dire ça c'est un truc tellement absurde
c'est la honte de l'humanité et je pèse
mes mots
vraiment je crois que tout ça finira
dans un bar sans quoi tout ça va se
terminer sur un banc
oui je m'en fous et faut que je sois
très clair là dessus je ne demande pas
de principes cas parce que je suis noir
et américaines j'aime tous les noirs
c'est pas vrai que mon cher ne va jamais
imaginé ça quelles sont les chansons que
tu regrettes de jamais avoir chanté au
cours de ta carrière tu t'y es vraiment
à le savoir
jose a pu le dire je peux que me pique
mon idée est ce que je vais le dernier
quand même il n'y a pas d'amour heureux
oui je me sens trahi
j'aimerais bien même si je ne connais
pas tu les paroles c'est une bonne
réponse toute façon tu as commencé à
chanter à trois ans dans les églises tu
prends pas en dieu sait quoi en dire
autant tous les dieux quels qu'ils
soient et s'auto là là je crois pas que
ton type de vita mais n'a à boire de
l'alcool à faire des excès soit en clair
maintenant le champagne j'adore ça en
toutes circonstances à n'importe où avec
n'importe qui mais je fais très
attention et c'est tout ce que je bois
et puis je filme je fume trop de
cigarettes mais je ne prends jamais de
dürer à part le champagne si tu
connaissais de la champagne est un mille
drogue
alors oui je me du rad je ne bois que de
champagne d'ailleurs est ce que tu
penses des chanteuses noires
d'aujourd'hui que whitney houston par
exemple l as de la chance tu connais
chad et enfin pas personnellement mais
elle s'est inspirée de moi tu savais ça
fait deux mois que tu penses de diana
ross
elle a la chance et elle est pas mal
mais voilà la chance d'aller au chan a
personnellement je n'aime pas ce qu'elle
fait j'ai fait cet événement 2 par
exemple
enfin il faut bien dire je suis la plus
forte entre brienz michael jackson et
terence trent d'arby qu'est-ce que tu
choisi michael jackson tu sais pourquoi
elle a énormément de talent et s'est
mutilé et c'est bien triste
à mon avis elle a fait pour échapper à 5
bling mais détroit c'est lui que je
m'entraîne dernière question c'est vrai
que ce n'est pas facile à vivre
oui je suis très bien c'est la vivre non
je plaisante
en fait je suis très simple est les gens
me demandent d'être profond tout le
temps j'aimerais que ça soit clair je
suis qu'un et quand je suis dans mon
appartement en voulons tout seul ou avec
certaines personnes je reste je suis
difficile à vivre
quant à me contre 816 ou anneaux quand
les gens avec qui je travaille ne sont
pas pros c'est tout moi je vois bien que
t'es pas très difficile à vivre
merci en bois un coup ça m'a plu et pour
être sûr de ne rien rater de
l'inaptitude abonnez vous mettez un
pouce bleus